[Music]
warby parker makes popular glasses
it also has a popular business model
brand selling mattresses luggage shoes
athleisure scrubs razors strollers
cookware bedding even hair color have
all been called the warby parker of what
it means to be the warby parker of is
basically to be an online disrupter of a
well-established
pre-existing category though relatively
cheap to start warby parker-like
businesses can be expensive to market
and many have failed warby parker
however has filed to go public hi we're
warby parker an eyewear company that
offers high quality glasses starting at
95
so as the now 10 year old glasses maker
prepares for its stock market debut
let's look at how the business works
it's a bit different than originally
envisioned
this is the economics of warby parker
warby parker launched in 2010 quickly
generating buzz with placements in gq
and vogue and gaining popularity with
its unique home tryon offer
i ordered five free pair of frames from
warby parker and we're going to try them
on it took what was usually a
in-store retail only
experience
and made it possible for customers to
get a miniature version of that from the
comfort of their homes these are i don't
like these i also got sunglasses oh
hey
you drive a sports car
the offer to try five frames for free
was essential for the brand when it
launched as less than one percent of all
glasses purchases were happening online
back then it's now about eight percent
so it's not necessarily about making a
sale in the moment it's about
whenever the customer decides that now
is the time to purchase glasses they
will feel good about warby parker and
their experience with warby parker the
real selling point and the founder's
initial focus was the price
the point was to
give the consumer a product that felt
like a designer frame but did not cost
what
people expect designer frames to cost
since its launch warby parker has sold
prescription frames starting at 95
how they do this is in part explained by
what they don't pay for including
licensing fees associated with producing
brand name eyewear and cost for
placement in major retailers instead
they streamline their process by having
in-house designers they work directly
with manufacturers for both the
manufacturing of the materials and the
building and assembling of the glasses
themselves
and all of that streamlining helps to
cut costs they can essentially pass
along those cost savings to their
consumers
or as the cliche goes they cut out the
middleman but as many similar brands
have discovered that's not enough to
make a company profitable
one of the biggest challenges for direct
to consumer business is getting eyeballs
getting customers you're really reliant
on digital marketing and word of mouth
and that costs money in 2020 when many
shoppers shifted online warby parker
spent an average of 40 dollars per
customer on a mix of advertising and
home
to pay for its expenses over the years
warby parker has raised 572 million
dollars in venture capital funding
its latest round which closed last year
valued the company at 3 billion
but it was money from a 2013 round that
funded an experiment for warby parker
that is now key to the company's
profitability
physical retail there's nothing quite
like walking to a physical space looking
around and feeling the essence of a
brand warby parker's first store was
here in manhattan's soho neighborhood it
now has more than 140 retail locations
in cities and malls across the us
the company says in-store sales average
2 900 per square foot annually they're
not really concerned about overall
profitability of the store locations
themselves because they really see them
as part of this customer relationship
for warby parker a sale online is as
good as a sale in store but it's worth
noting that sales are now split evenly
between the two
which marks a shift for what was
originally an online only brand even
though they have come in as a disruptor
they have with their retail locations
somewhat recreated
the traditional
purchasing process for customers the
stores help the company's bottom line
not just by generating sales but also by
stoking interest think of each store
like a street level billboard for the
brand you have actual discoverability
which is something that
direct-to-consumer businesses online can
struggle with you have foot traffic and
that's a way to start a customer
relationship by the end of this year
warby parker plans to have opened over
30 new stores and continue at that pace
in years to come to identify new
locations the company leverages online
data it knows where people are buying
and that allows the company to make
informed decisions on where it may pick
up new customers or drive people who've
maybe heard of the brand to check it out
so there is kind of this virtuous cycle
that is created where a customer can
find warby parker online or by walking
past the store
and as long as they complete a purchase
at some point in the future the company
really isn't too fussed about where they
do it
that's really warby parker's secret
sauce creating a model where the online
and in-store experiences work together
to drive sales
the next question can warby parker drive
investors the company confidentially
filed to go public in june and now says
it plans to do so via direct listing an
alternative to the traditional ipo for
companies that don't need to raise money
in a recent video to investors warby
parker's co-ceo said it was our goal
from day one to demonstrate that a
business could scale be profitable and
do good in the world without charging a
premium for it it's paperwork filed to
the securities and exchange commission
offers some clarity the company's orders
have increased slightly over each of the
last three years but warby parker still
isn't profitable
last year the company brought in 394
million dollars but ultimately logged a
loss of 56 million
how the oa on its future shares remains
to be seen
casper sleep a direct-to-consumer
mattress company went public last year
since its debut shares are down roughly
50 percent
if warby parker's listing can avoid the
same fate other warby parker of brands
will likely be taking notes